قصف منزل سيدها رامز عواد في الحي
الياباني كان يتواجد فيه 30 شخص استشهد 26
شخص من ضمنهم امها وابوها واختها واخوها
وحالتها من 3/11 لليوم زي ما هي في غيبوبه
وعندها كسر في الفك وكسر في ايدها
اليمين وكسر في الحوض وخلف في الضرر اللي
في راسها
وعندها في الطحال كمان عملوا لها
عمليه اجراء الاصابه كانت تحت الانقاظ هي
ومن 311 في نفس الحاله زي ما هي يعني ما
تغيرت خالص باي ذنب تقتل عائله
الطفله البن الريام لما تفوق وتطلع يعني
تطيب ان شاء الله وتصير بخير وسلامه حتى
نصدم ابوها مش موجود وامها واختها واخوها
يعني صدمه لها قبل لنا يعني هي في غيبوبه
حاليا ان شاء الله بطيب والله بشفيه يا رب
واضح انه هذه الحرب هي حرب ضد الاطفال
والنساء لانه ما يزيد عن 65% من حالات
الشهداء والاصابات هم من الاطفال والنساء
بالنسبه للاطفال ما يزيد عن 40% من
الشهداء والجرحى هم من الاطفال نحن نتحدث
عن اكثر من 8000 شهيد طفل لحتى الان
ونتحدث عن ما يزيد عن 20,000 طفل قد اصيب
خلال هذه الحرب 20 الف ما يزيد عن 30% من
اصاباتهم هي اصابات خطيره اصابات في الراس
او بتر في الاطراف او اصابات في العمود
الفقري او اصابات في البطن احتاجت الى
تدخلات جراحيه عاجله وكبيره مثل استئصال
الطحال او معالجه جروح الكبد او معالجه
النزيف في الرئه هذه الاصابات الخطيره
احتاجت الى وقت وجهد كبير و اصابت الاطفال
بضرر واعاقه
دائمه
[موسيقى]
مسك الحلاق كانت نازحه من بيتهم لبيت على
اساس تلاقي فييه الامان ولكن صار في قصف
لهذا البيت اللي نزحت
له وصل اخبار انه كل عيلتها استشهدت تم
نقلها للشفاء
ولما الاحتلال اتاح مستشفى الشفاء تم نقل
جميع الجرحى وكانت مسك من ضمن هذه الجرحى
اللي نقلوهم بدات جديد انه لما اقول لها
سيره بابا ماما دغري بتصير بابا وبتصير
تعيط البنت وكانها شايفاه انه صار في شي
وقت بتصير تنادي على اسماء بتنادي على انس
بتنادي على يحيى بتنادي على مسك بتحكي
كلام لما بسيبها وابعد عنها بتقول لي
تعالي
اقعدي يعني ان شاء الله انا حاسه انه في
تحسن وفي امل انه رب يش فيها بس تلاقي
اللي
يهتم